[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo ante la situación de kobe 19
ahora trabajamos desde casa imagina
tener la posibilidad de plantar árboles
en cualquier parte del mundo solo con un
par de clics o que incluso estos árboles
se siembren gracias a una actividad tan
cotidiana como realizar búsquedas en
internet pues en medio de las
preocupaciones sobre las catastróficas
consecuencias que traería el
calentamiento global dos plataformas en
línea lo hacen posible en esta edición
de revista digital les contamos cómo
funcionan empezamos
cada vez son más frecuentes las
advertencias de que si no hacemos nada
para reducir las emisiones de dióxido de
carbono nos enfrentaremos a las
catastróficas consecuencias del
calentamiento global pues los efectos
del cambio climático ya son una realidad
fuertes olas de calor incendios
forestales e inundaciones por ejemplo
los expertos han lanzado una serie de
recomendaciones
para combatir este fenómeno y una de las
muchas formas de hacerlo es a través de
la reforestación ya que son los árboles
los que absorben el co2 y producen
oxígeno y aunque no todo el mundo tiene
acceso a una porción de tierra para
sembrar un árbol en internet existen
diversas soluciones para hacerlo a
distancia
escocia es una de ellas se trata de un
motor de búsqueda como cualquier otro
pero lo interesante aquí es que con cada
consulta que hacemos contribuimos a que
se plante un árbol funciona así la
plataforma vive de la publicidad y
obtiene dinero cada vez que un usuario
hace clic en los anuncios que aparecen
en los resultados de la búsqueda el 80%
de estos ingresos es usado para
financiar plantaciones de árboles en los
países que más lo necesitan la mayoría
de ellos se encuentran en américa latina
áfrica y el sudeste asiático para poder
financiar la plantación de un solo árbol
un usuario deberá ser mínimo 45
búsquedas y no hay necesidad de contar
ya que la misma página hará el cálculo y
lo mostrará en directo como lo ven en
pantalla christian gross y yo de escocia
nos explica cómo impacta esto en el
medio ambiente
calculamos que en promedio cada búsqueda
elimina quizás alrededor de un kilogramo
de co2 de la atmósfera y luego decenas
de búsquedas cada día que se convierten
en miles cada año y eso significa que
unas cuantas toneladas de co2 son
eliminadas en total
en alemania la huella de carbono
promedio por persona es de 11 toneladas
así que cuando se eliminan varias de
estas toneladas hay en realidad un gran
impacto cuando se trata de luchar contra
el cambio climático y además de eso
estás ayudando a muchas personas creando
un mejor futuro
el propósito de este proyecto no es sólo
luchar contra las emisiones de carbono
las plantaciones también buscan
restaurar el hábitat de la vida
silvestre y combatir la inseguridad
alimentaria ya que la siembra de los
árboles es realizada por las comunidades
locales contribuyendo a su desarrollo
económico
queremos plantar árboles que beneficien
a las comunidades locales porque si
plantas árboles que necesitan o que son
apreciados por ellos entonces puedes
estar seguro de que no los cortarán
así que es la mejor garantía que tienes
de que tu proyecto es verdaderamente
exitoso cuando un pueblo entero hace
esto escuchas historias de cómo animales
en peligro de extinción regresan o como
los ríos están fluyendo otra vez o que
la gente ha vuelto a generar ingresos
y
así que los árboles son una especie de
inicio para un mejor futuro
decimos que no estamos sembrando árboles
sino esperanza
porque en muchas áreas donde estamos
activos el medio ambiente había sufrido
una degradación y cuando llegamos empezó
a mejorar
y por estado mental quieren ver otra
pionera en la siembra de árboles a
distancia strydom una plataforma que se
presenta como la primera en la web para
plantar de forma remota
aquí los usuarios pueden comprar la
especie de su preferencia y que está
disponible según la zona geográfica la
tecnología juega un papel importante en
este proceso el árbol es fotografiado
geolocalizado y monitoreado a lo largo
de su existencia y es una opción que
puede ofrecerse a alguien más a manera
de regalo durante el proceso se puede
ver cuán útil ha sido para el medio
ambiente o para las comunidades que lo
cuidan por ejemplo puede mostrar la
cantidad de dióxido de carbono que
absorbe así nos lo explica emma sin tres
directora de comunicaciones de freedom
en españa todas las informaciones de una
vez que tú vayas planta tu árbol se
vendan resumidas en el diario del árbol
es decir una página dedicada solamente
exclusivamente a tu árbol donde
recibirás notificaciones sobre el
proyecto que forma parte la
geolocalización del árbol digamos cómo
afecta la plantación a las comunidades
locales e incluso una vez el árbol esté
plantado vamos a enviar una foto del
arbolito nosotros vamos a ir enviando
actualizaciones conforme el árbol vaya
creciendo los árboles de tree en todos
los árboles de trigo aseguramos que van
a sobrevivir por un mínimo de 10 años y
si el árbol además no sobrevive durante
los dos primeros años de vida ya que son
los que más riesgos conllevan los
planteamos otra vez
según la página web una vez que se
compra el árbol puede tomar entre unas
semanas o varios meses antes de que esté
listo para ser plantado
freedom nos permitió explorar cómo
funciona el proyecto recibimos un árbol
de cacao que se encuentra en camerún al
momento de grabar este programa el
diario del árbol le indicaba que todavía
era un pequeño brote ubicado en un
vivero y que tan pronto como fuera
trasplantado se publicaría una
fotografía además de historias y
curiosidades sobre el país donde se
encuentra y los agricultores que lo
cuidan
de esta manera despedimos revista
digital recuerde que si quiere repetir
esta u otra emisión de nuestro programa
lo puede hacer a través de nuestra
página web www punto frente y cuatro
puntos